[applause]
Pausch: Allow me to deserve it.
This is--
man: LEFT IT.
Pausch: It's great to be here.
What Indira did not tell you was this series of lectures
once called "Last Lecture."
If he could hold the last lecture before his death,
what would it be?
I thought, "Damn, just when you mastered the subject,
they renamed it. "
So, in case someone has just jumped in
and he does not know the whole story
my father taught me,
When the "elephant in the room" (obvious questionnaire) to meet people with him.
If you look at my roentgen shots,
you can see that there are about ten tumors in my liver,
and the doctors predicted me
three to six months of healthy quality of life.
It was a month ago, so now you know how the account is.
I have some of the best doctors in the world.
So that's how it is.
We can not change that, and we can only decide
how will we react to that.
We can not change the maps that are shared,
but the only way we can play them.
If I do not act depressively or madly as I should,
I'm sorry to disappoint you.
[laughter]
And believe me, I'm not in the stage of denial.
Not that I'm unaware of what is happening.
My family, my three children and my wife, we just moved.
We bought a lovely house in Chesapeake, Virginia,
near Norfolk, and we did it
because it's a better place
for the family, on the road that expects us.
And another thing
I'm feeling really healthy right now.
I want to tell you how big it is
the cognitive dislocation that you will ever see
Just the fact I'm in really good shape.
Actually, in a better state than most of you.
[applause]
So, anyone who wants to cry or complain to me
you can go free and make a couple of these,
and then you can complain.
[laughter]
All right, well, what we are not going to talk about today,
We will not talk about cancer,
because I spent a lot of time talking about it,
and really lost interest in it.
If you know any herbal remedies or herbal remedies,
please, stay away from me.
[laughter]
And we will not talk about things
which are more important
from realizing their own baby dreams.
We will not talk about my wife.
We will not talk about my children, because I am well controlled,
but not good enough
to talk about it and not to break emotionally.
So we'll just get things out of the agenda.
These things are just too important.
And we will not talk about spirituality and religion.
Although I will admit to you how I did
fearful transformation.
I just bought a Macintosh computer.
[applause]
Well, I knew that I would win 9% of the audience.
Okay, so what are we going to talk about today?
About my baby dreams and how I did them--
I was very happy about that question--
as I think I was able to realize those dreams--
how could I realize the dreams of others,
and to a certain extent, the lessons learned from that--
I am a professor;
There should therefore be some lessons learned--
and how you can use the things you will hear today
to achieve your own dreams or help to realize the dreams of others.
How are you going to get married, you might know
how is the potential of other people's dreams
even more fun.
So what were my baby dreams?
You know, I had a really nice childhood,
I mean, without teasing.
I looked at the old archive of family pictures,
And what was really amazing,
I could not find my child's picture
where I did not smile, okay?
That was such a pleasant thing
Here are pictures of our dog, right?
Aaa, thank you.
and here is a picture that really sees me as I dream.
[laughter]
And I did it a lot.
Many times, "awakening moments," you know?
and that was the time when it was easy to dream imaginatively.
I was born in 1960, okay?
When you are eight or nine years old
and you look at the TV screen and see people coming down to the moon,
everything is possible,
and there is also something that should not be diverted from the mind,
that is inspiration
and the permission to imagine a big deal.
So what were my baby dreams?
You may not agree with this list, but I was there.
[laughter]
Being in the best state,
Play American Football in the National League
Being the author of the article in the "WORLD BOOK" encyclopedia--
It seems that dumplings can be recognized early--
[laughter]
Being Captain Kirk.
Is anyone else here having this baby's dream?
Not on CMU, No.
I wanted to become a jumbo of those guys
who conquer large plush animals at the parties,
And I wanted to work as a creator of attraction (so-called Imagineer) at Disney Park.
These dreams are not sorted in a particular order,
Although I think that somehow this is becoming more difficult to achieve,
except maybe the first one.
OK, so be in the best condition.
It's important to note here, how important it is to have specific dreams.
I did not dream of being an astronaut,
because I was already wearing a pair of glasses,
and they said to me, "Oh, the astronauts can not wear glasses."
And my reaction was, "Hm, so I did not want it
the whole astronaut performance; I just wanted to float. "
And - I'm like a kid--
[laughter]
Prototype variant 0.0.
It did not work so well, but it turned out as NASA
there is something called the Blind Comet
and that plane serves to attract astronauts,
This thing in the air performs arches in the form of parables,
and at the top of each port,
There is a time of 25 seconds moving ballistic
and it hurts to get the condition alike to the bumblebee
and it takes about 25 seconds.
And there is a program for which university students
can submit requests,
and if they win in the competition, they have the opportunity to fly,
so I thought it was cool.
And we had a team. We have teamed up,
who defeated them, and they were able to flee,
I was totally excited to go with them ...
And then I ran to the first wall,
Because they made it very clear
as in any situation to members who carry out faculty activities
he can not let him fly with the dunes
I know. My heart was broken, you know.
I was in a situation where you are thinking, "But I worked so hard."
And so I went to study the rules very carefully,
to turn out that NASA--
owns a program of its own publicity and openness to the media,
and it turns out that the students are consequently laughing
with him take local journalists from the local city.
[laughter]
Randy Pausch, Web Journalist.
It's really easy to get a PRESS card.
So I called people in NASA, and said,
"I need to know where to fax documents."
And they asked, "What documents will you send us?"
I said, "My resignation as a faculty advisor
and apply as a journalist. "
And he said, "Do not you think it's a little transparent?"
And I said, "Yes, but our project is a virtual reality,
"We will bring down a series of VR (Virtual Reality) head sets,"
"and all students from all teams"
"will experience this event"
"And they all make journalists"
it will be able to record it. "
Jim Folay says, "Oh, you bastard, yes."
And the guy says, "Here's the fax number."
And - really, we kept our part of the deal,
And one of the things you will listen to
later in speech
is to bring something to the table, eat,
Because it will make you more welcome.
And if you're interested in what the best-selling situation looks like,
Let's hope the sound will work.
male: Sound is on.
woman: All right, get them, Mazi.
This is fantastic.
Just miraculous.
Totally different from what I expected.
Pausch: Here I am.
[laughter]
Woman: This is amazing.
They've got eaten, Mazi.
That's good.
Man: I have a ball for you, Maz.
[Laughter]
Pausch: Man is paying his feet to the bottom.
So baby dream number one, Filled.
All right, let's go now to American football.
My dream was to play American football in national league.
And most of you do not know I'm playing fast - No.
[laughter]
No, I did not advance to the national soccer league,
but I'm probably more of a dreamer
and that I did not realize that dream
than what I got from those I did.
I had a trainer.
I reported when I was nine years old.
I was by far the smallest kid in the league,
And I had a trainer, Jima Graham, who was 195 cm high.
He played in the position of the last line in the Penn State club.
was a real bang,
and old school, I mean, really old school.
For example, he thought the front add-on was a trick move.
[laughter]
The first day of training came on,
and you know, it's really a bang of a man.
We all feared him to die,
And he did not bring any ball.
How will we have a ball training?
And the boy was asleep,
"Sorry, coach, but no balls."
Coach Graham replied, "Okay, how many players are there
on the soccer field during the game? "
"11 by team, 22."
and coach Graham asks,
"All right, and how many people
touching the ball at some point? "
"One of them."
And he said, "Well, we'll practice
in what remains of man works. "
And that is a very good story,
because everything is in basics, basics
basics, basics.
They have to master the basics,
because otherwise attractive things will not burn.
And my second story with Jim Graham
We had one training
where he ran all the way.
It's just the whole way, either "This is wrong, what you doing wrong.
"Come back from scratch. You owe me.
After training, you will do the work. "
And when it was all over,
one of the assistant coaches approached me and said,
"Oh yeah, Coach Graham put you really hard, did not you?"
I said, "Yes."
He says, "That's a good thing for you."
And then he said this, "When you're wrong
"and no one tells you anything about it,
that means they gave up on you. "
The lesson that has remained in the head for life,
that when you see yourself doing something really bad
and nobody is trying to tell you that,
it's a very bad position.
Critics are the people on your side who say so
how do you still love and love for you.
After Graham coach, I had another trainer,
coach Setliffa,
He taught me much about the power of enthusiasm.
He had this habit only once in every game,
let people play on, so like
the worst possible position for their game.
For example, he would set all low people as a ball bearer, right?
It was a laugh.
But we're just entering one attack, okay?
And, that was it, the other team never knew what had happened to them,
Because when you play just one attack
and you're not where it should be
and the word of freedom is the second expression for nothing to lose,
old, then you'll spit on somebody's way
That one attack.
and such a kind of enthusiasm was great,
Even today, I feel the most comfortable on the soccer field.
I want to say, that's one of those things where,
you know, when I handle a difficult problem
people will see me walk through the corridors
with one of these balls, and that's just it.
You know, when you do something early enough
And you work for that,
it simply becomes part of you,
and I am very pleased that American football was part of my life,
and if I did not realize the dream of playing in the NFL,
That's OK.
I've probably pulled out much more important things,
because when you look at what's happening in the NFL these days,
it seems to me that these boys and girls are just wonderful now and then.
OK.
And so one of the expressions
which I learned in Electronic Art, which I love,
which refers to this is, "Experience is what you are getting
when you do not get what you want. "
And I think it's absolutely wonderful.
And another thing about American football,
when we send our kids out to play rugby, soccer,
to swim or what already,
and that's a school example of what I'm going to call
stealth or indirect learning.
We actually do not intend to play football.
I mean, yes, it's really nice
which I can achieve a great hit worth three points
and what I know how to perform the bloom of the block
and all these things.
but we're sending our kids out to learn
much more important things:
teamwork, sportsmanship, perseverance, and so on,
And so on.
Such types of learning at the head of the head
is absolutely important,
and should be aware of them,
because they are all around.
All right, one simple,
Being an author in "WORLD BOOK" Encyclopedia.
While I was a child,
we had the "WORLD BOOK" Encyclopedia on the shelf.
For the brunette, that's the paper.
[laughter]
We used to have those things that are called books.
And when I became a bit of authority
in terms of virtual reality, but not as,
very important -
So I was at the level of people who would "WORLD BOOK" bother--
they called me, and I wrote an article,
and this is Caitlin Kelleher.
And there is an article if you go to your local library
Where are they still holding copies of the "WORLD BOOK" encyclopedia.
Look under "V" for Virtual Reality,
and there it is.
And all I have to say is,
I was chosen for the author
in the "WORLD BOOK" encyclopedia,
today I believe WIKIPEDIA is a perfectly good source
information
Because I know what quality control is
actual encyclopaedia.
They let me go (to write).
All right, next.
[laughter]
At some point, understand
as there are some things you will not do,
so you may just want to stand close to "those" people.
I want to say, God, what a role model for young people.
I mean, he's all you want to be,
What I learned and what carried me forward
while doing business later in life is that,
you know, he was not the smartest guy on board.
I mean, Spock was pretty clever,
and McCoy was a doctor, and Scotty was an engineer,
and then all you ask is, "What kind of skill did he possess?
that they put it on the forehead of that thing and that it was water? "
And, you know, obviously there is
a series of skills called GUIDELINES,
And, you know, whether you like this series or not,
no doubt how much could be learned
about how to lead people by just looking at that guy in action,
And he had the toughest toys.
I mean, my God, he, you know--
I was fascinating as a child
that he had this thing the injure he could,
you know, talk to the boat.
[electronic punch]
I considered him spectacular,
And of course, I now own one, and it's smaller.
and in some ways it's cool.
And so I made my own.
James T. Kirk - his alter ego William Shatner wrote a book,
which I think is actually a pretty cool book.
He wrote it as a co-author with Chip Walter,
pretty good writer from Pittsburgh,
And they're basically together
Science Star Trek, you know,
What has happened,
They traveled the country and the world in high tech locations
seeing different things,
they came here to study our device for virtual reality,
And so we built a virtual world for the sake of it.
It looks like this.
We started it, turned on the red alarm.
He was a great guy.
Not that he hoped.
And it is really the law to meet his idol from childhood,
But it's even better when he comes to you.
see what law you are doing in your lab,
it was simply a great moment.
All right, conquering stuffed animals.
This can work on the ground,
but when you are a small child and you see a big plush animal
while you walk in a fun park
and there are those big stuffed animals, are not they?
This is my lovely woman,
And I have a lot of pictures of plush animals I've won.
Here my stakes pose with the one I won.
I've won many such animals.
Here's my dad.
To honor him this one won alone.
[laughter]
Yes, this was easy
much of my life and life in my family,
But you know, I can hear cynics.
You know, at this time of digital manipulation of things,
maybe those bears are not really in the picture with me,
or maybe I paid $ 5 to somebody
to be in the party near the bear.
I wondered, "How in this era of cynicism,
can anyone convince anyone? "
And I said, "I know, I can show them the bear."
Bring them.
[applause]
If you can accommodate them there.
Just place them against the wall.
woman: It's hard for you to hear.
Pausch: Thank you, baby.
Here are some bears.
We did not have enough space in the truck to move
on the way to Chesapeake,
so everyone who wants a little pieces of me
at the end of this lecture, it can be freely available.
who first, his bear.
All right, my next dream, be Imagineer.
This was difficult.
Believe me, I'll be in the best condition
it is easier than to become Imagineer.
When I was a boy, he was eight years old
the family went on a journey to the state.
to see Disneyland, and if you've ever watched the movie
"National Lampoon's Vacation," was just so.
It was an adventure.
And these are real photos of that time,
here I am
In front of the castle, and this is me--
for those who like preaching,
This is Alise's ride in the land of miracles.
I thought this was the best environment
in which I have ever been. And instead of words,
"Oh, I want to experience it," I said,
"I want to create such things."
And so I waited for the opportunity,
doctorate
at Carnegie Mellon University, thinking it was me
unconditionally qualifies to do anything,
I just sent a job application
Walt Disney Imagineering Department,
and they sent me the most beautiful "carrying" letter to the worst
which I have ever received.
I mean, it was easy--
"We carefully considered your application,
"and we currently have no place at all
which requires your specific qualification. "
Keep in mind the fact that you receive this from the place
which is known for the types that target the street.
So, that was a bit of an obstacle.
But remember, the stone walls are there for a reason.
All right, the stone walls are not there to prevent us from entering.
Stone walls are here to give us a chance
show how much we want something,
Because the stone walls are here to stop people
who do not care enough about it.
They are here to stop other people.
All right, let's roll by 1991.
Then we developed a system at Virginia University
which was called 'Virtual Reality for $ 5 a day',
One of those incredible, spectacular things.
I was so scared of these early, academic days.
Jim Foley was there, and I just love to talk this story.
He knew my midwifery advisor, Andy Van Dam,
and I am at my first conference, and scared to death,
And it is an icon within the community that deals with user interfaces
He came over to me, and without a cause
just hugged me,
You said to me, "It's from Andy."
And then I thought, "OK, maybe I can do it.
All right, you know, I might really belong here. "
And a similar story
This device was an incredible hit
because at that time,
everybody needed $ 1/2 million to make the virtual world
and everyone was frustrated,
and we have literally skimmed the system
whose parts cost about $ 5,000, and created a VR device that works,
And people were able to, "Oh my God,
This is so, you know, as something from the Hewlett-Packard garage.
This is great. "
And so, I hold that speech, the room is in madness,
and during questions and answers, a man named Tom Furness,
which at that time was one of the great names in the development of virtual reality,
he went over to the microphone and played.
I did not know how it looks,
but I knew his name very much.
He asked a question and I wondered in wonder,
"Sorry, did you say you were Tom Furness?"
he replied, "Yes."
And I said, "Then I'll be happy to answer your question,
but before that, would he go to lunch tomorrow with me? "
[laughter]
And there's a lot in that tiny moment.
There is a lot of humility in the order
but also asks a person where she simply can not say 'No'.
[laughter]
And so Imagineering a few years later
worked on a virtual reality project.
It was a secret.
They have negated the existence of virtual reality attractions
and after the department for the public
he puts on TV commercials.
So the Imagineering Department really has sealed everything about it.
And it was about Aladdin's attraction,
where a man would fly on a magical carpet,
with a visualization tool mounted on the head, known as Gator Vizion.
And so I took the open entrance.
As soon as the project--
You know, they started to launch TV commercials,
and they asked me from the ministry of defense for the report
related to the question of virtual reality.
OK, Fred Brooks and I were invited
to report defense secretaries,
and it gave me an excuse.
So I called them.
I called Imagineering, and said,
"Look, I can report to the Secretary of Defense.
I would like to give you some materials about what you have,
because it's one of the best VR devices in the world. "
And they wanted to resist.
So I said, "Look, are these all pathetic things
in the park of the farce? "
They smiled like, "Hm, OK," but they said,
"But there is no public relations department ... This is like some news,
"But the Public Relations Department has no record for you,
"Well, we'll have to connect you
directly with a team that works at an attraction. "
Jackpot.
And so I get to talk over the phone with a man named Jon Snoddy
It's one of the most depressing people
which I've ever met,
and he was the man who runs the whole team,
No wonder they made impressive things then.
And so he sent me some things.
We talked a card.
He sent me some stuff, and then I said,
"Hey, I'll be close to you soon
"at a conference.
Would you like to meet me at lunch? "
Translation: "I'll laugh you
"and say I have an excuse that I'm in the vicinity
"so I do not seem too interested,
while actually going to Neptune to dine with you. "
And so Jon said, "Of course,"
After that I spent some 80 hours
talking to all VR experts in the world, asking them,
"If you had access to this incredible project,
what would you ask? "
And I did all this in the whole, and I had to remember it all,
and everybody who knows me knows it's not easy because I have no memory,
because I could not get there looking like a nerd,
you know, like, "Hello, question number 72."
And so I went, and it was, kind, lunch of two now,
to Jon now that he thought
how to talk to a phonemic person,
Because Fred Brooks passed through me
and Ivana Sutherlanda and Andy Van Dama
and the like, Henry Fuchs.
So, it's very easy to look smart
When you repent as a parrot of the words of smart people.
And at the end of that lunch with Jon I'm somehow,
as we say in the business, "asked the question."
And he said, "You know, my free academic year begins."
And he asks, "What is it?"
[laughter]
The beginnings of collision of culture.
So I talked to him about the possibilities
to come and work with him.
He also said, "Well, that's a very good idea, except,
"You know, you are in business
"to talk to people about things,
while we are at work where we keep secrets. "
All right, and then the thing Jona Snoddy did
I told Snoddy, he said, "but we will sort it out,"
And I really liked it.
The other thing I learned from Jon Snoddy--
I could easily talk about an hour
about all I learned from Jon Snoddy.
One of the things he said was,
"If you wait enough, people will surprise you and impress you."
He told me, "When you go for somebody
and you are angry at him,
"means that you have not given enough time to that person yet.
"Just give them some more time,
and will almost always impress you. "
And that really really left me in my head.
I think he's totally right with that.
But to shorten, we agreed on a legal agreement.
It will be the first--
Some people call it the first and last article
ever published by the Imagineering Department--
But the deal was to go there, I am funded,
I go to six months, work on the project,
and we publish the article.
And then we meet up with his own villain.
They can not be sweet and gentle,
because I do not have credibility.
Somebody's head will end up on the cart.
It turns out that the person with a head on the wheel
Dean at Virgii University.
His name does not matter.
We call it Dean Wormer.
[laughter]
So dean Wormer is sitting with me at a meeting where I say,
"I want to take that academic free year,
"because I managed to persuade these people from the Imageneering Department
to allow the entrance to the professor, "which is total madness.
I want to say that Jon was not a jerk,
this would never have enabled you.
It's a very silent organization.
And Sekan Wormer looks at the paper and says,
"Hm, so here it is written how they will own
your intellectual property. "
And I say, "Yes, we have agreed to publish the article.
"No other benefits. I will not work for the patents."
And he said, "Fa, but you could just as well, so this conversation will be gone.
"Just go to them and change this little paragraph
and then come again to me. "
And I'm like, "PLEASE?"
And then I told him,
"I want you to understand how important this is.
"If we can not solve this, two of us
"I will take unpaid vacation,
and just go there, and do that thing. "
And he says, "Hey, you know,
"Maybe I will not let you either.
"I think if you already have a design project in your head,
"it might just get you out of here,
so that's not going to happen either. "
[laughter]
It is very important to recognize the moment of "piercing competition"
and it is very important
as soon as they move away from such a situation.
So I said, "All right, let's get back a little.
Do we really think this had a good idea? "
He said, "I do not know if this is a good idea, you know."
And I mean, "OK, well, at least we agree."
Then I said, "All right, but do you decide about this?
Do not make these decisions 'dean for sponsored research'
if it's a research project? "
And he says, "Yes, that's right."
I said, "So if he is so happy, and you are happy?"
"Yes, then it would be okay."
poof!
Like Wilo Wild Coyote.
and find myself in the office of Gene Block,
who is the most fanciful man in the world,
let me talk to Gene Block, and I say,
"Let's start at the main level,"
that I do not have to go back to that.
"So let's get high.
Do you think this is a good idea? "
He said, "Well, if you ask me if this is a good idea,
"I do not have much information to judge.
"The only thing I know is a member of my college staff
"in my office, and that she was very excited,
therefore, tell me, please do more about it. "
This lesson for everyone involved in the administration.
They both said the same thing,
But think about the way they said that, okay?
"I do not know!"
"Well, I do not have much information,
"but one member of my college staff is here,
and he's completely excited so I want to hear more. "
Both of these ways to say do not know,
But, man, there's a good way and a bad way.
Anyway, we've all been relieved.
I went to the Imaging Department, sugar and glitter
And it's all good to be done well.
Some walls are made of meat.
So I worked on the ALADDIN project.
It was absolutely spectacular, I mean, just incredible.
Here's my nephew Christopher.
This was a developed device.
Sitting on this thing that looks like a motorcycle,
and would manage a magical carpet,
And put the screen on the head.
The video monitor mounted on the head was very interesting.
It was made of two parts, which was a very wise design.
To fit properly, the only part
who touched the visitor's head was this little cap,
and everything else was merged by clicking on it,
All set of equipment.
That way you could simply rip caps
which were basically very inexpensive to make.
This is what I really worked there,
I was a cap scalp during a free academic year.
I loved Imagineering.
It was just a spectacular place, simply spectacular,
All I ever dreamed of.
I liked a workshop for modeling,
people who sneak around the models that are the size of this room
which are simply great physical models.
It was just an amazing place to walk
and inspiration.
I always remember the time when I was going there and people were asking,
"Do not you think the expectations are a bit overdue?"
And I told them, "Have you ever watched the movie
"Charlie and the Chocolate Factory" -
"Willy Wonka and Chocolate Factory"
where Gene Wilder tells a little boy Charlie--
before deciding to give him a chocolate factory.
He says, "Well, Charlie, have you ever told someone
"a little boy story
who suddenly got everything he ever wanted? "
Charlie's eyes become big as a flying gun, and he says,
"No, what happened to him?"
Gene Wilder answers, "He lived happily for the rest of his life."
Okay, so work on Aladdin's virtual reality,
I describe it as
An opportunity that opens once in five years.
and stand in that estimation.
That changed forever.
Not that it was just about good business
although this is partly true,
but has led me to a place where I worked with real people
and on real-life user interface development issues.
Most professors live in this fairy tale world
white collar workers with doctoral and magistrate diplomas.
You know, until you get dirty with ice cream,
Do not deal with fieldwork, okay?
And more than anything else, I learned from Jon Snoddy
how together we connect the engineers and engineers,
and I consider it a real legacy.
We have published an article,
which was a nice cultural scandal.
As we wrote the article, people in Imagineering suggested,
"Well, let's put a pretty big picture
as they would put in a magazine. "
And for the Siggraph Commission, which received the articles,
it was a big scandal.
"Do they have to do that (put a picture)?"
[laughter]
There were no rules.
So we published the article, and surprisingly,
Since then there is tradition of Siggraph articles
they have colored images on the front side.
So, in a small way, I managed to change the world.
And then, at the end of those six months,
they came to me and asked,
"Would you like to do this forever? You can stay."
And I said, "No."
One of the few moments in life when I managed to surprise my dad.
It was a miracle, "Did you do what?"
He told me, "Since you were, you know yourself, you just wanted it,
and now that you get it, you are - Ha? "
There was a bottle of gorge in the drawer of my work desk.
Be careful what you want.
It was a particularly stressful place.
Imagineering was generally not a bad place,
But the lab I was in-- Oh, Jon went to the middle of the project,
And it was very similar to the Soviet Union.
It was a bit risky for a while,
But everything ended well,
And they said to me, "Stay here
or never cross over to this building, "
I would do that.
I would go for a ten-year experience.
I just would do it.
But they made it easier for me.
They told me, "You can eat and have a cake,"
And basically I became
Imagineering Advisor One Day a Week,
And I worked it for ten years,
And that's one of the reasons
Why should all become professors,
Because you can have and eat your cake, okay?
I continued as an advisor on things like DISNEYQUEST.
so there was a cruise to the Virtual Jungle
And the best interactive experience I've ever worked on--
and Jesse Schella Gzbog should praise it--
Pirates from the Caribbean, the goddess of Disney Adventure.
And so, that's my dreams from childhood,
And you know, that's pretty good.
I felt good about it.
And then the question arises,
How can I realize the children's dreams of others?
And again, man, I'm glad I became a professor.
What is the best place to accomplish dreams from childhood?
Maybe work in EA (Electronic Arts), I do not know.
It would probably be a good and close alternative.
This has started with a real concrete realization
To do that,
Because I'm a young man named Tommy Burnette,
while I was working at a university in Virginia,
He was interested in joining my development team,
We talked about it when he said,
"Oh, and I have a childhood dream."
It becomes quite easy to recognize them when they tell you that.
I asked him, "Yes, Tommy, what is your childhood dream?"
He said, "I want to work on the next" STAR WARS "movie."
Here you need to keep in mind the time when this happened.
Where's Tommy? Tommy is here today.
What would be the age? Your fucking year.
woman: somewhere there.
Male: Around 1993.
Pausch: Do you think any breakdown is in the back, young man?
OK, okay, so 1993.
And I said to Tommy, "You know
you will most likely not be doing these movies. "
[laughter]
And he says, "No, they will do them."
And Tommy worked with me for years
as an undergraduate and later as a member of the facultet staff,
And then when I moved to Carnegie Mellon University,
all members of my team
they came from Virginia to Carnegie Mellon
except Tommy, because he got a hefty offer,
And really, he did it all
three films.
And then I said, "Well, that's nice,
But, you know, (to realize people's dreams) once is somehow ineffective. "
People who know they know I'm crazy about efficiency.
So I wrote, "Can I do it massively?
Can I run people in this way
to turn to your dreams from childhood? "
And I created a course. I came to Carnegie Mellon,
and he founded the subject that was called "Creating Virtual Worlds."
It was a very simple course.
How many people here have ever been at any of the show?
OK, so some of you have an idea of what's going on.
For those who have not been trained, the course is very simple.
50 students are selected
from various departments at the university.
They are rendered randomly complex--
Randomly complex teams, four people per team,
and teams are changing at every turn.
One project lasts only two weeks, to do something,
something created, something to show,
After that I pronounce the teams, and you get three new colleagues,
And it all starts again, and it's so every two weeks,
In this way, you make five projects per semester.
In the first year we thought that this subject,
it is impossible to describe
how much we had a drag-and-drop situation.
I did this thing just for that
what I wanted to see if we can do it.
We have just learned how to build textures in 3D graphics,
and we could make things that looked half-full.
But, you know, we did it
on really poor computers by today's standards.
But I said, "Let me try."
At my new university, I made a couple of phone calls,
and said, "I want to make crossroads of students on this subject
to get all those other people, "and within 24 hours,
My subject was chosen by people from five departments.
I love this university.
I mean, That's so-- It's the most amazing place.
And the children were wondering, "What kind of content do we do?"
I said, "Damn it, I do not know.
"Do whatever you want.
There are two rules: No torture and no pornography. "
Not because I personally oppose this personally,
but because it has already been done through virtual reality, is not it?
And they'd be surprised at how many 19-year-old boys
stay completely without the idea of removing these two choices.
[laughter]
Anyway, I invented for the subject.
the first task, I shared them,
They've been back for two weeks, and they just kicked me off.
I mean, their work has overcome, literally, my imagination,
I copied the development process from Imagineering Laboratory for Virtual Reality,
but I had no ideas
What can be done with such an approach, and not with undergraduates,
And their tools were weak,
And they came back with their first assignment,
And I did something that was so spectacular
To literally not ... as a professor with 10 years of experience,
If I did not want to do anything else.
So I called my mentor.
I call Andy your lady, and I told him,
"Andy, he just split his two-week assignment,
"And they came back to things done
"for which I would have given them the entire semester,
"Everyone gets five.
Master, what can I do? "
And Andy thought for a minute, and said,
"Tomorrow is coming back to class,
"Look at them in the eyes, and tell them,
'people, this was pretty good, but I know you can do better.' "
[laughter]
And that was a real advice,
Because then he said this,
"You obviously do not know where the boundary should be set,
"And you'll just get them off
if you put it anywhere. "
And, people how good it was,
Because they only continued to advance, and during that semester,
it became a "matter of the underworld".
I would go to the classroom with 50 enrolled students,
And there were 95 people,
Because it was the day we showed the works,
And the names of students and friends and parents--
Never before did parents come to classes.
It was flattering and somewhat scary.
And so it started to snow, and we had that bizarre feeling,
"Well, we have to split this up."
If I was raised to do something,
it is to share, and so I split,
"We have to share this with others at the end of the semester.
We need to have a great show. "
And we booked this great lecture, Mcconomy.
I have many nice memories from this room.
We did not book it because we thought we would fill it up,
but because the only one had a projector with loudspeakers,
Because it was ZOO, computers and everything else.
And then we filled it up, and more than stuffed it.
People were standing in the passage.
I will never forget the dean of that time, Jim Morris,
who was sitting in the lab here somewhere.
We had to get him some way out of that place.
And energy in the room was something that never
before I did not, and chairman Cohen,
Jerry Cohen was there, and felt the same thing.
Later he described it as E
The Ohio Country Football Set Only for Academics,
He approached, and set up the very right question.
He asked, "Before somebody starts,"
He said, "I just have to know where all these people are from?"
He said, "Audiences, what are the divisions?"
And we randomly asked them, and they were from all departments,
And I felt very good,
Because I just got to this college.
He just came to this college,
And my new boss saw it in a very physical way
how this university brings together all the people together,
And that made me feel very much.
So we made a presentation before the whole university.
People are doing their work here.
They are in costumes, and we have shown up just like this,
And you can see what's going on.
You can see what they see
through the device on the head.
There are a lot of big props.
It was that rafting guy on the rushes.
this is Ben in "ET"
And yes, I told him not to do it
scene with a kid riding a bike in front of the moon,
to crash it.
That's the real story.
And I meant to show you just a little--
[laughter]
And I thought to show you only one world,
And if we can shake the lights, if possible.
No, OK, that does not mean.
Alright.
All right, we'll be fine then how best we can.
Rabbit: Oh, hello there.
[Giggle]
I'm lonely.
Make me the world.
[Giggle]
It!
Make me a tree.
[Giggle]
It!
OOH, That's nice.
[epska zborska muzika]
OOH.
LA LA LA
LA-LA-LA
LA LA
LA LA LA LA LA
LA LA LA
LA-LA-LA
This is fun.
[Giggle]
LA LA LA
LA-LA-LA
LA LA
LA
all WHEE!
Pausch: Now all this will be superstitious.
Watch carefully.
The world does not want to leave
and continue with the following display.
So she is ready to go, but the world is not.
Rabbit: What are you doing?
You can not finish this now.
woman: But there are so many other worlds that have also had to leave.
Rabbit: But our world is the best in the world.
Hey, hey, hey!
Hey, no!
not!
[Giggle]
Here I am.
woman: We'll quit you.
CONTROL, ALT, DELETE.
rabbit: no CONTROL, ALT, DEL--
[laughter]
[screaming]
Rabbit: He left us.
HE LEFT US.
[screaming]
My skin.
My skin!
[Screaming and Attacked Shoots]
[Screaming]
We loved you.
Goodbye!
[laughter]
Pausch: It was a neophyte course
With some of the most brilliant, creative students
Everywhere from university.
It was a pleasure to be involved in this.
And all that aspect of the show they realized
check and pre-order.
[laughter]
It became a university phenomenon every year.
People would stand in line for that.
It was a very bearish,
And he gave the kids a sense of excitement
What kept the play for the others who were so excited about it,
And I think it's one of the best things
which you can give to someone,
A chance to see what it is like
other people excite and be happy.
I mean, It's a terrific gift.
We have always tried to include the audience,
Whether it was people who hold lightning sticks
or by adding a ball to the beach, or a ride.
It's really cool.
This technology was even used and
at the premiere of "SPIDERMAN 3" in Los Angeles
So the audience managed something on the screen,
That's a nice way.
I have no class image of all the years,
But I extracted all that I have,
And you just say what a privilege is
and it was a honor to teach this subject
some ten years ago,
All good things come to their end,
and so I stopped groaning that thing about a year ago.
People always wonder what was my favorite moment.
I do not know if it may be your favorite moment,
But, man, he was the one I'll never forget.
I think it was the Ninja world on roller coaster,
One of the rules was to make the show live,
and all worlds were supposed to work,
And if they stopped working at some point,
We came back to show the recorded material,
And that was very scandalous.
So we had that Ninja onstage,
And he drives on the roller coaster,
And the world crashed "not gently".
Whoosh.
I went out,
I think it was Steve Audia, did not it?
Where is?
OK, where's Steve?
AH, my man, Steve Audia.
Talk to me about speeding, okay?
He told him, "Steve, I'm sorry, but your world has collapsed,
We will include the Video tape. "
And he pulled out his ninja sword and shouted,
"I'm embezzled! WHA!"
And just falls.
[lsmijeh i aplauz]
And I think he's talking a lot
how is my favorite moment
in ten years of this subject with high technology
this brilliant improvisation.
After the recording ended and the lights turned on,
he lies stationary there, and his colleagues pull him away.
It was a fantastic time.
And there was a lot of people connecting to the course.
People knew to ask, Do you know,
"What will result in a good world?"
He would have told them, "I do not know how to tell you in advance,
"But shortly before the presentation,
"I can tell you if the world is good
"by the body's speech.
"If they are close to each other,
the world is good. "
Creating virtual worlds was a pioneer subject.
I will not be bored with all the details,
But it was not easy to do it,
I got this when I came down from the head of the head,
and I think it's significant.
If you're going to do any pioneering job,
you will get those arrows in your back,
And you just have to screw it up.
I mean, all that could go wrong, went wrong.
but at the end of the road,
a lot of people had fun.
When you have something
ten years, and so daringly precious,
it's the toughest in the world
to surrender,
and the only advice I can give you is,
find someone better than you to surrender,
That's what I did.
That kid had long been in the studio for virtual reality,
and you should not spend much time
near Jesse Schnella to say,
"The force is strong in this."
And one of my biggest--
my two greatest achievements, we, for Carnegie Mellon
is what I got to Isac Hodgins and Jesse Schnella
to come here and join our faculty,
And I was thrilled that I could hand it over to Jesse,
And to no surprise,
he took the whole thing a line further,
and the object is in more good hands.
He's in better hands.
But that was just one item,
And then we really raised the thing,
and create what I like to call a dream-filled factory.
Don Martinelli and I got together,
and with the blessing and support of the university,
make that thing out of pure fabric
which was absolutely crazy,
it did not have to try it.
All reasonable universities did not even approach this thing,
Creating an incredible opportunistic gaps.
So the entertainment technology center
They were knocking on artists and technologists
who worked in small teams to do things.
It was a two-year master's degree,
Don and I were two kind souls.
We are very different.
Anyone who knows us knows
how are we two very different people,
And I like doing things in a new way,
And the real truth is
that we both feel a bit more relaxed in the academy.
I used to say I feel uncomfortable as an academic
because I come from long lines of people
who really worked for life, so ...
[laughter]
I notice a nervous laugh.
I want to emphasize that, Carnegie Mellon
the only place in the world
where the entertainment technology center (ETC) could develop,
far from all, the only place.
OK, this picture is not Don's idea, okay?
And we like to address this image
like Don Marinelli on the guitar and Randy Pausch on the keys.
But we really did manage to play the left half of the game, the right half of the brain,
And it was supposed to get a good profit in that way.
Don is an intense man.
[laughter and applause]
Don and I shared the office,
At first it was a small office.
We've been working for six years, okay?
All of you who know Dona know that he is a very fierce man,
And you know, considering my present condition,
someone asked me-- It's a terrible joke,
but I will apologize,
Because I know that Don will forgive me.
Someone asked, "Taking into account your present condition,
"Have you been thinking about it
do you go to heaven or hell? "
I replied, "I do not know, but if I go to hell,
for six years I have already served. "
I'm joking.
Share a office with Done
it was like sharing a tornado office.
There was so much energy,
And you never know what the next thing is going to be right, right?
But you knew that something exciting would happen,
And there was so much energy,
And I believe that credit should be recognized where they are deserved.
So if I show it in my typical, visual way,
if Don and I shared the ETC success,
it is without doubt a lion's share.
He deserved to do the lion's share of the job okay.
He had a lion's share of ideas.
It was a great team work.
It was a great Yin and Yang combination,
But it was more like "YIN" and yang.
It deserves that confession, and I give it to him,
because the ETC is a wonderful place,
and he now leads him, and takes him to a global level.
We'll talk about that for a second.
The description of the ETC is really difficult,
And ultimately I found the metaphor.
Talk to people about the ETC
is like describing CIRQUE DU SOLEIL
to someone who has never seen him.
Sooner or later you will make a mistake.
You will say, "Well, it's like a circus."
And then take you to a talk about,
"Oh, how many tigers there are; how many lions there are;
okay, how many points on the trapeze? "
And that's the whole bit.
So when we say we are graduating for a master's degree,
we are not really like
A single master degree degree you've ever seen.
Here's the curriculum.
The curriculum eventually took on this form.
I just want to show you visually
as are five projects that deal with the creation of virtual worlds.
There are three more things to do.
All time is spent in small teams, doing things,
There is no 'learning from the book'.
Don and I did not have the patience to learn from the book.
It's got masters degrees.
They have spent four years learning from the book.
All right, so far, they should have read all the books.
The keys to success were
what Carnegie Mellon gave to us,
He gave his hand in his hand.
We should not give a statement to any dean.
We reported directly to the pro-Rector,
What's great, since it's a redirector
overwhelmed to watch you carefully.
We got a clear permission to break the mold.
Everything was based on the project.
It was intense.
It was fun, and we had field trips.
Each spring semester in January,
would take all 50 students from the first year,
and took them to the PIXAR store (idea).
They would take them to PIXAR, INDUSTRIAL LIGHT AND MAGIC,
And of course when you know guys
like Tommy who hosts you there, sign,
It's pretty easy to get in to such places.
So, we did things very, very differently.
Such projects as the students would do,
We did a lot of what we called EDU-TAINMENT.
We've rolled out a bunch of stuff
with the New York Fire Department,
A network simulator for firefighters training,
using technology similar to that for video games
to teach people useful things.
That is not bad.
Companies have begun to treasure a strange thing.
They put it in writing, "We promise we'll hire your students."
I keep here letters from EA and ACTIVISION.
I think we now have such, five, five?
Drew knows, I bet.
So there are five written agreements.
I do not even know about another school
who has such a written agreement with any company,
and that is the right expression.
And these are the things that matter for many years,
So they agree to hire people
on summer internships that we have not yet received in school.
That's a pretty powerful message
about the quality of this program.
And Don, as I said, He is now-- He's crazy.
And I think it is a wonderful, commendable way.
Doing those things to me, "Oh, my God."
Tonight is not here because it is in Singapore,
Because he is going to set up an ETC study at the University of Singapore.
It already exists in Australia,
And one will exist in Korea.
It therefore becomes a global phenomenon.
I think that says a lot
about all other universities.
It is true that Carnegie Mellon is
the only university that can do something like this.
The only thing we need to do now is around the world.
Another great success with the ETC
is learning to be angry to focus--
Oh, I hear the nervous laughter of students.
I forgot what a shock therapeutic effect
these bar charts.
While the subject of Building Virtual Worlds is taking place,
Every two weeks is received for each feedback.
This is all put on a big pile,
and at the end of the semester,
he had three teammates per project,
five projects.
this is 15 data points.
which is a statistically valid quantity.
And you get a column column telling about your placement
about how easy it is to work with you,
How do you measure with other peers?
Man, such a rating is hard to ignore.
Some still succeeded.
[laughter]
But in most cases, people would look at it and say to themselves,
"You, I need to boost the pace.
"It's better to start thinking about what I'm talking about
people at those meetings. "
And that is the greatest gift the educator can give
Encourage someone to become self-critical.
The ETC is beautiful,
but even with ETC and with DON that spreads it around the world,
It's a very hard job, you know.
It's not like Tommy's case that one man works.
it is not about a development group of ten people.
It is 50 or 100 people per faculty of four faculties.
But I wanted something that could be infinitely enlarged, okay?
Enlarge to the level where the million
or tens of millions of people
you can hunt your dreams with something.
And, you know, it seems to have that goal
I really act like a crazy hat.
ALICE is a project we have been working for a long, long time.
It's a new way of learning computer programming.
Kids make films and games,
e - again, we got back to the head.
The Best Way to Learn Someone
to make them think they learn something else.
I do it through my entire career.
The boss's head here is what they learn to program,
but think they just learn to do movies and video games.
That thing has already been downloaded
got over a million times.
The eight manuals are written about it.
10% of us university members are just using it,
And that is not the real thing either.
Things are coming in the next version.
I, like Moses, have a look at the promised land,
I will not go on it,
but that's fine because I can see it,
and the vision is clear:
Millions of kids who are having fun while learning something hard.
That's pretty cool.
I can handle it as a legacy.
The next version of the program will be released in 2008.
They will learn programming in JAVA programming language
If you want to know how to learn JAVA.
Otherwise it will simply think
How to write a script for the movie.
And we take the characters
from the best-selling PC games in history, "THE SIMS."
And all this already works in the lab,
So there is no real technological risk.
I have no time to thank and mention everything
from the ALICE team,
But I would like to say that Dennis Cosgove
to build it, it already builds it.
he is a designer.
it is his baby, and for all who are wondering,
"Well, you know, for a few months,
who should contact the email regarding the ALICE project, "
Where's the marvelous Dann?
Oh, there you are.
Get up, let everyone see you.
Everybody say, "Hello, Wanda."
all: Hello, Wanda.
Pausch: send her an e-mail.
And I'll still tell you something about Caitlin Kelleher,
She completed her doctorate
and is located at the University of Washington,
and she will do this a little bit further
and go to high school.
Dagle, a great vision, and its continuation
If you can live in something,
I will continue to live through the ALICE project.
All right, and now the third part of speech,
Lessons Learned.
We talked about my dreams.
We talked about helping others to realize their dreams.
Somewhere along that road,
there must be some insight
in allowing you to realize your dreams.
First, there is the role of parents, mentors, and students.
I was blessed to be born into the family of two incredible people.
is my mother in my 70's birthday.
I'm back here.
He just overcame me.
This is my dad on the slope of death on his 80th birthday,
He states that, you know, he is not only brave;
Even as he was talented,
Because he also won the big bear that same day.
My dad was full of life.
Whatever he did with it was an adventure.
I do not know what's in that bag, but I know it's a law.
My tat dressed in Santa Claus,
But he also made very important things
to help many people.
This is a dormitory in Thailand signed by my mom and dad,
And every year, about 30 students go to school
Which could not possibly be.
That's something
in what we are deeply involved in and my wife and I,
and that is the kind of thing
which I think everyone should do, help others.
But the best story we have about our father--
Unfortunately, my dad passed away
Just a little over a year ago,
And when we looked at his things--
He fought in World War II in the Battle for Bulge--
and when we reviewed his stuff,
we discovered that he was honored with a bronze star of heroism.
My mother did not know that.
In 50 years of marriage, it never came to an end.
My mom.
Moms are the people who love you even when you bite them for hair.
And I have two great stories about Mom.
While I was studying here to earn my doctorate
and while I took something called Theoretical Qualification,
For what I can definitely say
that is the second worst thing in my life after chemotherapy ...
[laughter]
And I complained to my mother
about how difficult this exam is
and how horrible it was, and she just bowed,
he patted me by the hand, and said,
"We know how you feel, sweetheart, and remember,
when your father was your age, he fought against the Gentiles. "
[laughter]
After I got my doctor, my mother enjoyed it
to represent me like, "This is my son.
He's a doctor, but not the one who helps people. "
[laughter]
These slides are a bit dark,
But while I was in high school, I decided to paint my room.
I've always wanted a submarine and an elevator.
And the wonderful thing about this is--
[laughter]
What to say?
And the wonderful thing about this one is,
that they allowed me,
And they did not get upset about it,
and it's still there.
If you go to my parents' house, it's still there.
And to all who are here and who are their parents,
if he wants a child to paint his bedroom,
as a service to me, allow him that, okay?
Everything will be fine.
Do not worry about the house's sales value.
Other people who help us with our parents: our teachers,
our mentors, our friends, our colleagues.
God, what about Andy Van Dam?
While I was burning at Brown, he was on leave,
And all I was listening to was Andy Van Dam.
He was like a mythical creature, like Centaur,
But as a really ruthless centaur,
And they were all, kind, very sad
which is not but there is more relaxed in one hand,
and I learned why,
So I started working for Andy.
I was assistant lecturer during the 2nd year of study,
and I was a pretty arrogant young man,
And I came during the evening,
and of course, it was 9:00 pm,
Andy was there in the evening,
what's your first indication
about what the professor was.
And I went inside, and, you know,
I was like - I'll save the whole world.
All these children are waiting for help,
blah blah, blah blah, blah blah, blah blah.
And after that, Andy literally flipped me (in the style of "Dutch uncle") - he's a Dutchman, okay?
He frowned upon me,
He put his hand over my shoulders,
We went to a small walk,
when he said, "Randy, that's a pity
"what these people experience arrogant,
"because it will limit
what you can do in life. "
How damn good way to say "You act like a monkey."
Is it?
He did not say "You're a jerk."
He said, "People are experiencing you that way,"
and he continued, "the bad side is, which will limit it
what you will be able to achieve. "
When I met Andy better, plunder became more direct.
[laughter]
I could talk to you about Andy for a month,
But the one I'll apologize for is from the time I was supposed to
start thinking about what I'm going to do
After graduating from Brown,
I would never have been in million years
to go to postgraduate, from my own imagination.
It was not a kind of thing people made of my family.
We did, say, how do you call them?
Jobs.
Andy said, "No, do not go to work.
Go to your doctor. Become a professor. "
I asked him, "Why?"
And he said, "Because you're so good a salesperson
"that every company that gets you
"Use it as a trader,
"And the last case could sell
something that is worth it like education. "
Thank you.
Andy was my first boss, so to speak.
I was lucky enough to have many bosses.
The red circle is far off.
Al is located here.
I have no idea what happened there (on slides).
Probably this looks over the internet video transmission and speaks,
"My God, he is fired, and he is still unaware of it!"
I do not want to talk much about the great bosses I had
In addition to saying they were great,
And I know that many people in the world had bad bosses,
and I did not have to endure that experience,
and I am very grateful to all people
to which I should have to carry out the examiner.
They were simply unbelievable.
But it's not just about our bosses.
We also learn from our students.
I think it's the best "headshot" of all
came from Caitlin Kelleher--
Forgive me, Dr. Caitlin Kelleher--
which graduated from college right here
and starts working at the Washington University,
She looked at ALICE
While there was an easier version for learning programming,
and she said, "Yes, but why would that be fun?"
And I have an attitude, "Well, because I'm an impassioned man.
"I love to move small toy soldiers around
when they do it on my command, and that's fun. "
She imagined, "Hmm."
And she was the only one she said,
"No, we'll get to it all as a story story."
And she did a fantastic piece of show that,
especially with high school girls,
if you present it as a story-telling activity,
They are completely willing to learn
how to write computer programs.
So the reward for the best winch slaps
goes to the dissertation of Caitlin Kelleher.
(Professor) President Cohon, when I told him
that I will hold this lecture,
he told me, "Please excuse them for fun,
Because you remember that. "
I replied, "I can do it, but it's like a fish
talks about the importance of water. "
I want to say I do not know how to do not have fun.
All right, I'm dying, and I'm having fun,
And I will continue to have fun every day that has left me,
Because there is no different way to do that.
Alright?
So my next tip,
You just have to decide Are you a Tigger (happy figure tiger)
or you are Eeyore (a shabby sling figure).
I think it's clear where I stojikm
As for the big Tigger-Eeyore debate.
Never miss a peculiar amazement.
It's just too important.
It moves us forward.
Help others.
Denny Profitt knows more about helping other people.
He forgot more than I would ever know.
He taught me his example of how to work with a group of people,
How to marry people.
MK Haley-- I have a theory
that people coming from large families
better people,
because they simply had to learn how to live with others.
MK Haley comes from a family who had 20 children.
Yeah, incredible.
He always says, "It's kind of fun to do incredible things."
When I first came to Imagineering,
She was one of the people who measured me,
and she said, "How do I understand
"you joined the ALADDIN project.
What can you do? "
I said, "Well, I'm a professor of computer science with an indefinite contract."
And she said, "Well, that's a very nice professor boy,
"but that's not what I asked.
I asked, 'What do you know how to work?' "
[laughter]
And, you know, I mentioned in some way, your roots from the working class.
We keep what we value, what we value,
and I kept my Letterman jacket all this year.
I liked to wear it during undergraduate studies,
One of my friends, Jessica Hodgins, would ask,
"Why do you wear that Letterman jacket?"
Then I would look at all non-athletic guys around
who were much smarter than me, and said, "Because I can."
She understood this as a true coffin,
Well, for one year she made this little wrinkled Randy doll.
And he has a little Lettermen jacket.
He loves me all the time.
It is a perfect gift for egomanians from your life.
So that I met wonderful people during my life.
Faithfulness is a two-way road.
There was a young man named Dennis Cosgrove
at Virginia University, and while he was a young boy,
Let's just say that some things have happened,
and I found myself in conversation with the dean, and the dean--
No, with that dean.
Anyway, this dean really intended to Dennis,
and I could never Fudge why,
because Dennis was a fine guy,
but for some reason,
that dean really had a pimple.
And he ended up talking to me, "No, I guarantee Dennis."
And that guy says, "You have not yet got a working contract for a permanent,
and you tell me you're gonna guarantee
for this student the second or the first kind that has been in the past year? "
I think he left the first year at that time.
I said, "Yes, I will guarantee for him,
because I believe in him. "
And the dean said, "And I'll remember it
When your contract is signed for an indefinite period of time. "
And I said, "Agreed."
I came back to talk to Dennis and told him,
"I would really appreciate it if you-- it would be okay."
But loyalty is a two-way road.
I want to say, that happened before God knew how many years,
But that's the same Dennis Cosgrove
Which carries the ALICE project forward, forward.
He stayed with me all those years, okay.
And, you know, to choose one person
that we send it into space in a space capsule
to make contact with the extraterrestrial, I choose Dennis.
Speech at Carnegie Mellon University can not be held
without giving recognition to a very special person,
and that's Sharon Burks.
I was kidding with her.
I told her, "Well, look, if you're retiring,
it is no longer worth living. "
[laughter]
Sharon is so wonderful, it can not be described,
and for all of us who helped,
That's unbelievable.
I like this picture,
Because it is located along with Syl,
and Syl is great,
because Syl gave me the best advice
which I have ever heard,
And I think all these young ladies should hear this.
Syl said, "It took me a long time,
"but I realized that much.
"When it comes to men who are romantically interested in you,
"It's really easy.
"Just ignore everything they say
"And just pay attention to what they are doing.
That's easy. It's so easy. "
And I remembered my little days,
And you're saying, "Damn it."
Never give up.
I did not immediately go to Brown University.
I was on the waiting list.
I called them, and they finally decided
that I became tiredly boring
because I called every day so they let me in.
At Carnegie Mellon, I did not go to postgraduate studies.
Andy was my mentor.
He said, "Go to postgraduate studies.
"You will go to Carnegie Mellon.
All my good students go to Carnegie Mellon. "
And, yeah, you know what's going on.
And so he told me, "You will go to Carnegie Mellon,
no problem."
He forgot that he was a hacker
to enroll in the best PhD program in the country
really grew,
and also did not know that I would undermine my ratings,
because he believed in me,
What, on the basis of my points,
was a really stupid idea,
So I did not go to Carnegie Mellon.
No one knows this until today.
I'm telling you a story.
I was refused entry to Carnegie Mellon University,
And I behaved somewhat unbearably as a little kid.
I went to Andy's office,
he threw a letter to the desperate Lna desk.
and told him, "I just wanted to let you know
"how much your letter of recommendation is worth
on Carnegie Mellon. "
[laughter]
And before the letter touched the desk,
his arm was on the phone, and he said,
"I'll fix it."
[laughter]
And I said, "No, No, No,
"I do not want to do that.
"It's not the way I got upset.
"You know, maybe some other postgraduate schools
want to promise. "And he said," Look.
Carnegie Mellon is the place to go. "
He said, "You know what, I'll make a deal with you.
Go visit other schools. "
Because I went to all the other schools.
He said, "Go and visit other schools,
"And if you do not feel comfortable in either one,
will you give me then to call Nico? "Nice about Nico Haberman.
And I agree, "OK, agreed." I went to other schools.
Without a specific appointment-- Berkley, Cornell--
They were there to be so unkind
that I found myself talking to Andy,
"You know, I'll get hired."
And he said, "No, you will not,"
He received the phone and spoke in Dutch.
[laughter]
He hung up the phone and said,
"Nico says if you're around this serious,
you'll be in his office tomorrow morning at 8:00. "
For all of you who know Nico,
This is really scary.
So I'm in Nico Haberman's office
the next morning at 8:00 pm,
Story with me, and frankly,
I do not seem to grow up for that meeting.
I do not think he's a little enthusiastic either.
And he says, "Randy, why are we here now?"
And I say, "Why did Andy call you?"
And I said, "Well, in the meanwhile since you refused me,
"I won a scholarship.
"The Naval Research Bureau,
"It's a very distinguished society.
"I won a scholarship,
and that was not in my papers when filing (on fakltet). "
And Nico replied, "Money from society, we have a lot of money."
That was still at that time.
He said, "We have plenty of money.
"Why do you think that you own a scholarship
is there any difference to us? "
And then he looked at me.
There are moments in which life is changing,
and ten years later,
if you retrospectively recognize some of such moments,
you are blessed,
But be aware at the very moment
Nico is watching you through the soul ...
Then I replied, "I did not intend to imply
"anything related to money.
"I just say that it was an honor to receive it.
"These scholarships were distributed only to 15 across the country,
"and I wanted to say it was an honor
"how this is something commendable,
and I apologize if it was drastic. "
He smiled, and that was fine.
So then, how do you get people to help you out?
You can not get to that myself.
People will help you, and I believe in karma.
I believe in backlinks.
You get these people to help
telling the truth, honestly.
Each time I prefer to choose honestly through a cheerful person - hit,
Because it's cheerful in the short term.
Honestly in the long run.
Excuse yourself because when you make a mistake and focus on other people,
Not to yourself.
I was thinking about how to do it
a concrete example of this?
We have a concrete example
focus on someone else there?
Could they bring it that way?
You see, my wife was a birthday yesterday.
If ever there was a moment I got the right
be focused on yourself,
then that would be the Last Lecture.
But I feel bad
which my wife did not have the opportunity to celebrate her birthday properly,
And I thought it would be nice if 500 people--
[applause]
everyone is singing: Happy birthday you.
Pausch: Her name is Jai.
Happy birthday, dear Jai.
Happy Birthday to You.
[congratulations and applause]
Pausch: You have to put them out.
Alright.
[applause]
Now you will have another additional reason
to come to the reception.
Remember, the walls allow us to show their perseverance.
They are here to separate us
of people who do not really want to
to achieve your childhood dream.
Do not quit.
The best gold is at the bottom of a full-barreled barrel.
[laughter]
Steve did not tell you about the academic free year at EA.
I was there for 48 hours and loved ETC.
We were the best.
We were favorites,
And then someone pulled me upside down and said,
"Oh, by the way,
"We're getting $ 8 million in USC
"to develop the program just as you have.
I hope you will want to help them get started with that. "
[laughter]
Then Steve met him and said,
"They said what? Oh, my God."
And to quote the famous man, "I'll fix it."
That's what he did.
Steve was an incredible partner,
and we both have a great relationship,
personally and professionally,
and he was undoubtedly a forehead
in creating game factors to facilitate the learning of millions of children,
and you know, that's unbelievable.
But, you know, it would be sensible
that after these 48 hours I went to the free academic year,
but it would not be the right thing to do,
And when you do the right thing,
Good things somehow come back.
Make a feedback and listen to it.
The back link can be even a foolish graph I used to use,
or it can be a great person
which tells you what you need to hear.
The hard part of it is to listen to it.
Everyone can be proud.
Rare are the people who say, "Oh, my God, you're right,"
Unlike, "Do not Wait, The Real Reason Is What" -
That's what we all already heard.
When people provide feedback, appreciate it and use it.
show gratitude.
When I got an employment contract for an indefinite period, I took my entire development team
in Disneyland for a week,
Another professor from Virginia University asked,
"How can you do that?"
I told him, "These people broke my teeth for me
"and got me the best job in the world for the rest of my life.
How could I not do that? "
Do not grieve; Just work harder.
This is Jackie Robinson's picture.
In his contract he stated that he should not complain,
even if the fans spit on it.
Be good in something; This makes you precious.
He works diligently.
I got a contract for an indefinite year, as Steve noted.
Younger employees of the faculty knew to tell me,
"You've got an earlier contract on indefinite terms.
What is your secret? "
He would say, "It's very easy.
"Call me any Friday evening at the office at 22:00,
and I will tell you. "
Find the best in everyone.
One of my things Jon Snoddy,
As I mentioned, what he told me
is that you may have to wait a long time, sometimes for years,
but people will show you their good side.
Just keep waiting, no matter how long it takes.
Nobody is completely harm.
Everyone has a good side.
Just keep waiting.
That will come out.
And be ready for it.
Happiness is what happens when the preparedness meets the occasion.
So today's speech was about dreams from childhood,
realizing the dreams of others, and some lessons learned.
But did you make a headache?
It was not about how to realize your own dreams.
It was about how to lead a life.
If you live life in the right way,
Karma will take care of herself.
Dreams will come to you yourself.
Did you make a second headache?
Speech is not intended for you.
It is intended for my children.
Thank you all. Good night.
[applause]